après une lourde angoisse d'haroun
saxena n'attend qu'une chose enfin
revoir son fils rapatrier d'ukraine
son fils pilloud j'étais coincé en
ukraine depuis le début de la guerre
avec près de 700 autres étudiants
indiens
aujourd'hui le groupe est de retour au
pays sains et saufs
[Musique]
une opération compliquée pour la
diplomatie indienne qui a dû négocier
avec les deux camps pour un couloir
d'évacuation la fin d'un calvaire pour
que ses étudiants réfugiés dans des
résidences a soumis au nord-est de
l'ukraine à quelques kilomètres de la
frontière avec la russie à cours de
vivres il décide alors de poster un
appel à l'aide sur les réseaux sociaux
cette vidéo a poussé les autorités à
accélérer le sauvetage des étudiants
nous avons parlé à l'un d'entre eux
quelques heures avant l'évacuation
le pire a été évité
officiellement un seul indien a été tué
en ukraine ces deux dernières semaines
au total l'inde a rapatrié plus de 17000
personnes à bord de 90 vols spécialement
affrétés